[Musique]
je vous présente bel une nouvelle
étudiante sa cause de la maison le 112
ocean avenue bien pervers tu me suis
dans la rue la qua non la maison te dit
quelque chose
comment tu sais où j'habite tout le
monde sait où tu habites en 1974 la
maison a poussé au lieu des griots
assassiné toute sa famille nous l'avons
trouvé six membres d'une même famille
tout cela battu pourquoi t'as rien dit
pour la maison c'est qu'une histoire de
fantômes c'est légende urbaine
cette maison va être bonne pour james tu
me manques vachement
j'ai vraiment un mauvais sentiment par
rapport à la maison rien d'effrayante ci
est passé depuis maintenant 40 ans 40
ans c'est un chiffre très significatif
dans la bible la région fut en paix
pendant 40 ans peut-être que la force
maléfique s'empare de quelques heures
tous les quarante ans et cette maison
elle est uniquement font mal
cette chose maléfique ce serait mon père
et de mon frère qu'est ce qu'il y a
quelqu'un d'autre à l'intérieur de tous
trouvent le moyen pour empêcher le mal
de sortir
il y a une chambre en bas à la carte
j'ai vraiment un mauvais sentiment par
rapport à la maison je crois qu'elle a
une influence néfaste sur tille elle va
convaincre gm de tuer toute notre
famille
[Musique]